un stage de voile longtemps un prétexte
pour les policiers qui venaient ici la
honte d'avouer où il se rendait et
pourquoi la dépression un mot presque
interdite dans le milieu de la police et
pourtant la profession est gangrené à
tous ces niveaux
jean-luc gérard hervé voilà
comme hervé et alain ils sont des
centaines chaque année à venir se
ressourcer dans cette clinique de la
campagne tourangelle des policiers
détruit par leur métier
pourquoi sont-ils si nombreux à en
arriver là
peu d'entre eux ont accepté de témoigner
mais tous ont réussi l'essentiel faire
le premier pas avoir envie de se soigner
je suis un policier qui a consommé de
l'alcool qui était rentré dans une
habitante logis et puis qui veut s'en
sortir qui se dit qu'après tout la vie
n'est pas finie à 50 ans qu'on a le
droit à une deuxième chance et j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir me la donner et
redevenir ce policier que j'étais qui
aidait qui protégeait public voilà c'est
ça que j'attends du pourboire
les acteurs ont tous dit faire ça fait
réagit d'achille des six très hauts
fonctionnaires par rapport à lui qui a
fait moins de chi pour vous je vous
donne plus mais c'est grâce pas rentrer
dans ce jeu là mais du roi où il veut et
c'est dans le bureau de billy titus les
langues se délient
en début de séjour cet employé membre de
la police reçoit des confrères au bout
du rouleau comme hervé vous allez rester
au plein de normes je vous parle ce taux
plein moi je retourne sur le terrain
avec mes gars cet entretien a un goût de
délivrance déception des illusions
consternation les mots sont nombreux
pour parler de la réalité du métier
pression des chiffres ramenés temps
d'affaires par jour les stats leur
proposer une prime pour certains s'est
cassé une solidarité entre collègues
voilà pourquoi il suffit que le policier
rentrer chez lui que ça n'aille pas trop
non plus le policier a besoin d'écouté
il sait pas trop ce retour n'est donc
silva chez lui ça se passe pas trop bien
y retourne au boulot ça se passe pas
bien non plus avec la hiérarchie
policiers se retrouvent dans une heure
il ya aucune porte qui s'ouvre à lui
hervé marielle est en arrêt de travail
depuis plus d'un an brigadier-chef dans
la région parisienne
ce quinquagénaire en dépression c'est
qu'il a atteint un point de non-retour
sa déchéance professionnel et personnel
a commencé le jour où il s'est senti
plombé par sa hiérarchie dans une
période difficile de sa vie
je me souviens de cette phrase terrible
quand il me dit notamment
mais regardez vous regardez la gueule
que vous avez la tête que vous avez vous
avez les yeux complètement mix aux mains
tommies et les yeux tout rouges et je
lui dis mais comment danse c'est tout
simplement parce que j'ai du mal à
dormir la nuit je me remet difficilement
de cette opération
hélas une longueur me dit mais j'en ai
rien à faire et si vous seriez mon frère
je vous mettrais ma main dans la gueule
nous cassera la gueule et ça ça m'a fait
mal très très mal j'ai pris ce qu'on
appelle un coup de poing à l'estomac à
coups de poing qui nous met ko debout et
qui personnellement vous touche
c'est ce normand bien sûr et de la com
vous vous sentez que vous n'êtes plus
rien que vous ne représentait plus rien
au niveau de la hiérarchie
c'est pas comme ça qu'on se redresse et
bien on chute on continue des prix mais
on consomme de l'alcool
et puis mon bal le mal étant mais on
pense au suicide
on pense au suicide et j'y ai pensé dans
les couloirs de l'établissement
ils sont nombreux à avoir pensé mettre
fin à leurs jours
cet ancien capitaine de la police
judiciaire de nice en fait partie il a
aujourd'hui quitté la profession
une retraite anticipée pour échapper au
harcèlement moral de ses supérieurs
je vais montrer une partie de pourquoi
je suis là
lille aussi l'administration s'est livré
à son égard à des agissements répétés de
harcèlement moral qui occupe pour objet
ou pour effet une dégradation des
conditions de travail ont porté atteinte
à ses droits et sa dignité d'altérer sa
santé physique et mentale est compromis
sur l'avenir professionnel
si la justice lui a donné raison
difficile pour lui de tourner la page je
leur en veux toujours le lieu d'une part
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été sanctionnés
pénalement et d'autre part c'est que en
compromettant ainsi mon avenir
professionnel
en me rendant malades moi j'aurais
préféré continuer je serai maintenant
commandant de police
le dernier échelon si c'est peut-être
commandant fonctionnel et bon j'aurais
pu me réalisés en plus d'amants d'un
métier que j'adorais mois dans que j'ai
cru que j'aimais et non non je suis très
déçu je suis déçu je dessinais ça fait
plus mal lorsqu'on est une femme qu'on
aime que si une personne qu'on s'en fou
dont on s'en fout des taux sous un voile
avant moi j'étais juive et la police et
certains gros plus mal selon une étude
de l'inserm l'institut national de la
santé et de la recherche médicale
le risque de suicide dans la police est
supérieur de 36% à celui du reste de la
population
presque un suicide par semaine en france
des actes que l'administration tente de
passer sous silence difficile d'avouer
que le mal vient de l'intérieur
même quand tout le laisse penser le
symbole est très fort puisque dans
beaucoup de cas de suicides ce sont les
policiers qui se sont mis en tenue et
qu'ils se sont donné la mort avec leur
arme de service c'est dire combien le
symbole est fort nous nous savons au
cours bas que ça n'est pas pour des
raisons personnelles que c'est
effectivement lié au travail de certains
policiers se trouvent dans une impasse
souffre de la non-reconnaissance souffre
de difficultés diverses et variées y
compris avec leurs collègues
donc oui c'est intimement lié au travail
l'organisation aussi provoque des
risques psychosociaux particulièrement
important mais principalement il nous
parle du manque d'écouté et de la non
reconnaissance pour aider les policiers
à sortir la tête de l'eau
le centre place le sport au coeur de sa
thérapie
beaucoup sont des anciens sportifs
retrouver la forme est une étape
essentielle de la guérison
on se remet en question et ce que je
veux quelque chose encore en tient aux
sportives on s'aperçoit qu'on n'est pas
si mal que ça
souvent quand ils arrivent ici sont sur
quoi nous sommes sûrs fois
il ya beaucoup de plaintes
douleur
et au fur et à mesure la seconde compte
mu et puis c'est aussi
s'aimer
comme c'est totalement
si t on
être fier
[Musique]
retrouver la confiance en soi passe
aussi par la création dans cet atelier
les patients font travailler leur
imagination
un exercice difficile en début de séjour
certains dessinent des tombeaux des
corps sans tête
une manière d'évacuer des souvenirs
douloureux l'objectif c'est qu'il ya un
mieux être de la personne
enfin elle est même déjà tout simplement
et qui est prise de plaisir à venir ici
a à construire quelque chose créer c'est
transformer ses données via quelque
chose on s'autorise à être satisfaits de
soi même alors qu' il ya des moments où
on doute de beaucoup de choses
enfin quand on est vraiment dans la
maladie on doute de tout on est on se
dit qu'on est nul qu on est capable de
rien que et puis il ya ces petites
choses
depuis quelques années les femmes sont
plus nombreuses aux courbes à christelle
a quitté son commissariat il ya bientôt
deux mois
l'art et l'écriture sont pour elle un
exutoire
ça me fait du bien des moments où malgré
tout malgré toutes les occupations et
tout on a envie de se retrouver un peu
seul
donc je viens dans la chambre j'écris
j'écris j'écris ce fait ça fait un bien
fou
c'est un journal quoi petit journal de
bord brigadier dans le val d'oise
celle qui se décrit comme une flic est à
la dérive a passé neuf ans dans la
brigade accident il période de sa vie
toujours difficile à digérer
ballet les images le les les victimes
encastrée dans des amas de tôles suite
des accidents des accidents frontaux des
refus priorité des je veux dire c'est
pas joli à voir quoi et c'est dur à
gérer
on ne nous prépare pas ça on nous
prépare en école en nous disant vous
risquez quand même de voir des choses
dures aller sur des ouvertures de portes
découvrir des cadavres etc
on sait qu'on sera amené à côtoyer la
mort mais
je dirais aussi souvent et sans rien
derrière
c'est dur moi ce qui s'est passé c'est
que j'ai emmagasiné emmagasiné
emmagasinée et que malheureusement ma
soupape de temps en temps c'est l alcool
quoi l'alcool comme moyen d'évacuer huit
patients sur 10 ici sont sous traitement
pour réussir à se sevrer
on sait que c'est mauvais pour la santé
mais pas ou continue parce qu'on n'est
pas forcément bien dans sa tête et toute
addiction
et pas bonnes par principe quoi c'est
moi je dirais que dans mon cas c'est un
petit peu un suicide lent quoi
ces derniers mois le centre a enregistré
un nombre record de demandes d'admission
le résultat d'une politique du chiffre
poussé à l'extrême par le gouvernement
précédent les activités
ce ne sont pas des travaux ce sont de
l'occupation pour vous occuper pour
aller de l'avant et 8 et le retourner
sur le passé
le passé c'est le passé mal en vous êtes
ici une led l'avant tous les vendredis
le personnel encadrant accueille les
nouveaux arrivants parmi eux de plus en
plus de jeunes
c'est très inquiétant d'abord parce que
c'est celle envers notre république m
donc le fait de plus en plus jeunes
vieux copains et c'est inquiétant
j'assure non pas qu'ils aillent encore
un malentendu mais l'état dans lequel
vous
ça de notre hérisson à 28 ans michael a
souhaité témoigner mais à visage couvert
les bras le long du corps
[Musique]
ce héros tout mais les pieds vers
l'extérieur
cinq ans seulement après son arrivée
dans la police il est en épuisement
professionnel
ce qu'on appelle ici le burn out vous
allez commencer à vous concentrer sur
votre respiration
je suis ici pour accepter non fait du
jour au lendemain je mangeais plus je
dormais plus les médicaments que le même
temps aux médecins généralistes mais les
deux ne faisait pas du tout les faits
jugés sûrs d'eux mêmes les doses et
jallet sur par exemple ont concédé une
semaine j'avais perdu sept kilos et en
fait ça donc ne peuvent simplement
accepté en fait il fait la démarche de
numéros ici pour pouvoir pour pouvoir me
sonné s'est inquiétée à quel point bas
au pas ou je veux la morale mais depuis
deux ans il travaille dans un centre de
rétention où sont détenus des immigrés
légaux
un poste auquel il a décidé de tourner
le dos et partent avec la boule au
ventre ou est ce qu'on sait pas comment
va revenir le soir avec quel problème
quelle difficulté
nous on n'a pas d'armée et les mecs qui
sont en face de nous n'a la nature donc
en fait on n'est pas du tout en sécurité
derrière la carrière du policier un
homme meurtri par une solitude
insupportable moi demain je n'ai pas le
problème en émane est archi all in
medieval enfoncée et quand je vous dis
mon fond c'est l'amendement foncé plus
d'acteurs
donc ça va 2 par exemple moi j'ai déjà
entendu lors de certaines réunions des
officiers parler des problèmes
personnels de collègues et d'insulter
ses places ses collègues de leurs
propres effectifs des cassos de pauvre
merde j'en passe quoi donc vous quand
vous savez des choses comme ça vous avez
pas vous retournez vers ces gens là peau
pour demander le nom de plus de
solidarité
en coulisses c'est un groupe de parents
s'est fait attention si vous retournez
en service vous n'avez pas bien il faut
savoir que vous avez maintenant à
nouveau un numéro vert quelqu'un vers
qui vous dirigez et parler dire voilà ça
va pas mieux ça va pas bien il ya des
endroits où on sait très bien que la
hiérarchie ne joue pas son rôle des
hiérarchies qu nous ça va nous aider à
bien identifier le lieu à bien
identifier savoir si c'est un cas isolé
si c'est vraiment l'intégralité du
management qui va pas envoyer pour nous
c'est très important
un policier rentrer dans la peau lisse
et sans fort on lui a pas appris à à
ressentir des choses qui pourraient le
mal c'est un sentiment de honte
vis-à-vis des autres
il
[Musique]
deux mois après son arrivée le moment
est venu pour alain de quitter le centre
[Musique]
je me sens comme étant sorti du tunnel
avec des lumières qui j'espère sera de
plus en plus vive pour les amis c'est le
jour du départ s'est passé avec un gros
pincement au coeur
la confiance un jeu c'est quelque chose
que j'ai appris à que j'ai appris à
connaître ici
moi je tiens à dire que j'ai été pendant
19 ans abstinents après être resté après
mon séjour au couvent
c'est un joyau c'est je compare ça un
gros bijoux dont vous êtes donc chacun
de vous est une pierre précieuse à vous
de la faire rayonner de façon à faire
rayonner ce magnifique instrument
magnifique outil qui est unique c'est
unique et apprécié surtout mon jeu c'est
en partant j'ai appris à apprécier
je connais un peu la vie vraiment ce
qu'on fait pour nous
[Applaudissements]
hervé lui a décidé de prolonger son
séjour soigner mais pas guéri beaucoup
de policiers appréhendent de retrouver
la réalité du terrain
lui n'aura pas changé sarah mes mots
non
or
[Musique]